comprometidos con la defensa de su país
estos ucranianos que viven en el
extranjero esperan un tren en la
frontera con polonia para volver a
ucrania un viaje inverso al de los
millones de refugiados que huyen de la
guerra como esta enfermera
no volveré para ayudar soy enfermera y
los hospitales necesitan más ayuda y me
quedaré allí hasta el final
me encantó
desde eeuu este hombre quiere proteger a
su país de nacimiento
quiero que mis hijos y nietos puedan
visitar una ucrania libre quiero poder
visitar mi pueblo o vivir en mi pueblo
con mis cuatro hijos pequeños
desde el comienzo de la invasión rusa
más de 180.000 personas han regresado a
ucrania para defender su país algunos
ucranianos toman las armas y fabrican
cócteles mólotov en caso de un ataque
mientras que en este centro de acogida
de mykolaiv los voluntarios distribuyen
alimentos una muestra de solidaridad que
se observa en todo el país en la capital
rodeada por las tropas rusas estos
voluntarios ayudan a los refugiados que
han huido del oeste la mayoría a pie no
se plantean la posibilidad de abandonar
el país
sólo porque somos ucranianos no podemos
hacer otra cosa no podemos irnos cuando
nuestra gente está muriendo aquí no
podemos irnos a una resistencia civil a
favor de su país que pone en riesgo su
propia vida